along with displaying the genome
sequence shown at the top of the genome
browser image the genome browser also
allows us to view various tracks aligned
with the genome sequence in the lower
portion of the browser image a tract is
a visual representation of a dataset
related to the genome sequence above it
tracts can show data from diverse
datasets such as gene predictions mRNA
or RNA seek expression data sequence
similarity to other organisms and
information about repeats and variation
associated with a certain region of the
genome depending on the researchers
goals it is often helpful to display
only a subset of the available evidence
tracks you can control the display mode
of each track through the drop-down
lists at the bottom of the genome
browser page for example the tracks that
show sequence similarity to other
organisms and the gene models from
different gene predictors are available
under the genes and gene prediction
tracks category each track has up to
five display modes for example if we
click on the drop-down list for the base
position track the first track under the
mapping and sequencing tracks category
we can change the display to one of the
three display modes available hide dense
or full in contrast if we click on the
drop-down list for the gap track we will
see the five display modes that are
available hide dense squish pack and
full to better understand how the
display modes affect the genome browser
image we will experiment with the
different display settings for the
d-mail proteins track scroll down to the
genes and gene prediction tracks
category change the display mode for the
de mail proteins track to hide and then
click on the refresh button hide means
this particular track will not be shown
at all now we will change the display
mode for the D mail proteins track to
dense and
and hit refresh dents means the selected
track is displayed with all features
collapsed into a single line
irrespective of whether there are
overlapping features in this case you
can see that all the features in the D
mail proteins track are shown in one
line this mode is useful for reducing
the amount of space used by a track when
you don't need to access the individual
items or when you just want to get an
overall view of the distribution of the
features along the genomic region of
interest let's now change the display
mode for the D mail proteins track to
full we see that there are many more
features in the D mail protein section
of the genome browser image that is
because the full display option shows
each annotation feature on a separate
line because this display mode may
result in an overwhelming number of
items it should only be used when you
are examining a small genomic region to
reduce the height of the genome browser
image we can change the display mode for
the D mail proteins track to pack in
pack mode the track is displayed with
each annotation feature shown separately
and labeled but overlapping features are
shown on separate lines
hence this display mode offers a good
compromise between the dense and full
display modes the final display mode
squish is similar to pack mode but each
feature is shown at half the height of
the features in pack mode this allows
the genome browser image to show more
data per inch of screen height this
display mode is particularly useful for
high density data tracks such as
displaying all of the RNA secrets that
have been mapped to a genomic region
you